I put this uniform on but the uniform is
not who I am
it doesn't make who I am still a black
man I'm still proud of Who I am
even when I put the uniform on
or in my community you feared law
enforcement but I don't think fear is
the way in which you keep the community
safe I think you keep a community safe
by having a partnership and I see it I
mean I grew up in Oakland California and
the west side of Oakland I grew up in a
very violent area as a young young boy
we would often just run from law
enforcement because we would just
believe that they were gonna harass us
or do something she was I was taught to
not trust police and not to look to
police to protect me or protect my
community
my responsibility to my community is to
not only be a professional police
officer but to also be empathetic to the
issues that the community face but these
issues are real to me we often in this
class will tell you what true legitimacy
what is it it's not the fact that what
you do how you behave with a point in
camera action right it's how you behave
when I am sleep at 2:00 in the morning
can I rest because I've confidence at my
police department that my police
officers in Georgia ready if you don't
trust something if you don't believe in
a system maybe you should be a part of
the change in that system you know
especially as african-americans we have
to prepare our young people to become a
part of law enforcement we have to put
people that we trust in place so I think
that people can't just stand by and say
I hate something I hate something I
think for those that's it like they
could be that positive force that that
law enforcement means they should is she
getting wrong